In no particular order, here are the top 10 most notable children's authors.
Number 10. Margaret Wise Brown.
Once, there was a little bunny who wanted to run away.
So he said to his mother, "I am running away."
"If you run away," said his mother, "I will run after you."
Number 9. E. B. White.
It's a beautiful medal, Wilbur.
And you deserve it.
Are you alright, Charlotte?
You don't sound like yourself.
I'm a little tired perhaps.
But I feel peaceful.
Your success today was to a small degree, my success.
Number 8. Judy Blume.
In my house, reading was something to be cherished.
I mean my parents were both readers.
They didn't know a lot about education.
But they knew how important it was to read.
And they never would have said to me,...
...we don't want you to read this book...
...because it was a good thing to read.
And all of the books on the shelves in my house were available to me.
Number 7. Laura Numeroff.
If you give a mouse a cookie, he's going to ask for a glass of milk.
When you give him the milk, he will probably ask you for a straw.
Number 6. Beatrix Potter.
I have not seen many rabbits moping.
But when they do, their ears droop.
Peter Rabbit was in low spirits.